now everyone has that one teacher that
they will never forget
perhaps a teacher who helped you when
you were really struggling someone who
at the time you thought was the best
teacher in the world they probably still
are to you today well Andrea Saphira COO
is an arts teacher from North London and
she really is the best teacher in the
world she's the first UK winner of the
global teacher prize for her work with
children as she's here with us now in
the studio
Angie congratulations I think thank you
so much so good to have you with us but
before we talk to you you're going to be
very I would imagine downplaying your
achievements but let's hear from the
prime minister who's picking you up
Andrea Zafira cool
[Music]
Andrea Zafira COO who recently won the
global teacher prize
it is a fitting tribute for everything
she has done and I look forward to
meeting her shortly to Karachi later in
person they get an invitation from the
Prime Minister please don't be modest
Andrea how does it feel to be the best
teacher in the world I still can't get
used to that sight so I don't think I
ever will
it feels tremendous it's a fantastic
honor and it's a great responsibility
that I now have for all and I represent
all the teachers in the country but
things like this opportunities like this
do not happen without the help of people
such as His Royal Highness Sheikh
Mohammed and the Varkey foundation who
believed in teachers and have put on
this incredible opportunity for us to
have a great platform it's interesting
you talk about the responsibility that
comes with this title because we always
talk about the fact that schools in this
country are struggling to recruit
teachers and retain teachers so you
really want to promote a positive
message about teaching and not
concentrate on the negatives I do and
I've met some incredible teachers on
this journey and for the global teacher
prize and they are from all over the
world but I know that our teachers here
are incredible we work so hard and they
are so dedicated to the children which
they have in their classrooms and they
go above and beyond so this is for us
teachers this is for us and I'm so happy
and I would hope that they are happy
that I have I'm here to represent them
as well
yeah you really are the poster woman for
teachers tell us a bit about your school
because it's outlets in community
schools it's in Brent North London not
far from the studios here I know you're
heading to school after this your first
day back what a welcome you'll get and
but tell me about Brent because it's one
of the poorest areas in the country it's
one of the most ethnically diverse so
that in itself presents a lot of
challenges for you yes but we don't see
them as challenges we see them as great
opportunities our children do have tough
lives and that's no secret but the what
we like to do is make sure that the
moment they come into our school gates
those labels those issues they don't
matter
they're here to have a great education
that we're here to look after them and
just making sure that we do whatever it
takes
and for them to be on the right path and
in that borough alone 130 languages are
spoken and you have to talked about the
diversity of your school and a lot of
the children speak different languages
so to make them feel comfortable and
included you've been on a language
course or to yourself not at all I I
understand how intimidating it can be
for any child to come into a school and
not being able to speak English I mean
that's a huge huge issue for them so
just to be able to say hello and welcome
them and to greet them into our
community could you say hello where are
you it's it's important because what
they do is they just feel warmth they
feel that they can connect with our
community in our school community and
that's a great thing
so you include them by overcoming that
back language barrier but you also do
other things to include them and make
the school a safe haven
what other measures have you gone
because in the in the nomination you
your head teacher talks about you going
above and beyond doing so much extra for
children not just you know within school
hours and within the curriculum and I
think and I don't think it's something
that I do alone I think that as teachers
we teach in our classrooms but what's
more important is what happens outside
our classrooms and the relationships
that we build up with our students
knowing what they're like what their
interests and making sure that in terms
of their pastoral provision we've got
them we look after them and we put
things in place for them to make sure
that they can achieve and it wasn't just
an apple for teacher you've got this
incredible truth in it and he also got 1
million dollars which I'm sure for you
is the icing on the cake what are you
going to do with that money because
you've said that you actually want to
use it to help the children so as you
know I'm really passionate about the
arts and the arts curriculum I believe
is a powerful tool and bearing in mind
that our students do come from
disadvantaged backgrounds I would like
to think about how I can use that to
engage our children more in the creative
aspects of all of the arts because I'll
find they're incredible tools what would
you say to anyone that is
thinking of becoming a teacher because
as I said we read so much in the
newspapers about struggling to recruit
lack of resources long hours difficult
circumstances without a doubt it is the
best job in the world I can't imagine
doing anything else I love going into my
school building you are so inspiring and
the Prime Minister is looking forward to
meeting you got an invitation yesterday
and it was it was a whirlwind day and it
was incredible and you know it's
delightful to meet them I bet you're
looking forward to seeing the children
more in the about an hour I should be
back at school if you get a quick
message for them because I know they'll
be watching this morning knowing that
you're on them just can't wait guys
can't wait see you soon wait turn up on
time being class on time will be very
exciting
I will thank you so much and my pleasure
thank you very much so inspirational and
an absolute pleasure to have you in this
morning well done and congratulations
keep up the good work thank you so much